I just want to reiterate something
manifestations are real and people you
bring up in the past randomly will
somehow be a part of your life this is
not the same thing no it is this is not
it is I was just scrolling Tik Tok and I
come across this guy I had a physical
reaction like my stomach flip-flopped
and I was like I'm in love you mention
this actor's name probably three times a
day for the last two months his name is
Callum Turner you guys have probably
heard of him now because cuz he's dating
dualipa this man lives in London we're
walking a block away from our apartment
cine turns over and looks at me and goes
that's call him Turner she thought I was
full of and I go don't play lo and
behold is my celebrity crush on our
street on our street you made a circle
at three times I made a circle he was
waiting to dig inside I like kind of
touched him with my elbow a little bit
you're so you were trying to do like a
meat C I didn't want him to notice me I
just wanted to see if I could like how
close I can get are you okay